ce mercredi 24 août 16 ouvriers de
l'office national des forêts ont été
honoré en recevant la médaille d'honneur
agricole
elle comporte quatre échelons de
l'argent pour 20 ans de service à grand
or pour quarante ans en passant par le
vermeil et l'or dans la médaille
d'honneur agricole et qu'on pense à la
fois pour des salariés dans le secteur
de l'agriculture ou de la forêt à la
fois la durée des services et là on aura
des camarades qui ont presque à entendre
les deux services et surtout la qualité
des services donc ce n'est pas une
médaille automatique c'est pas une
médaille à l'ancienneté
il faut vraiment n'a mérité faut être
proposé par tout l'encadrement qui
reconnaissent donc tout la qualité des
services du travail fait par ses
ouvriers courageux au service bas de la
réunion de leurs espaces naturels
la présidente du département nassimah
dindar a souhaité remettre en personne
ses médailles
elle a rendu un vibrant hommage à ses
ouvriers pour le travail accompli
le département nous sommes nous fiers
honoré que ces agents forestiers et pu
mettre leur savoir être leur
savoir-faire à contribution de la
politique départementale en faveur de la
protection de nos forêts nous sommes nos
propriétaires de 90% des forêts de l'île
et si ces forêts nos sommets ont pu être
classé au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
c'est grâce à ces ouvriers forestiers
qui pour certains depuis plus de 40 ans
30 ans amènent leurs connaissances dans
un métier qui est à la fois technique
compliqué est rude
une médaille qui pour ces travailleurs
représente un véritable honneur la
reconnaissance de leur savoir-faire de
leur implication et de leur courage à
deux mains et polyvalent mais c'est à
dire que me fais la concession des
gosses
est en réfection du chantier les tables
bon à tous que dix sites touristiques à
leurs élèves et tous a dit son entier
mais fait aussi intérim et se trahissent
la hausse à la joie de vivre et c'est un
honneur au moins malgré la médaille en
fin de deuxième vingt quand plus qu'à
remonter leur médaille d'argent 1 joie
d'y mentionner le gouvernail c'est un
honneur pour moi tout paris la
reconnaissance de mon travail
les tâches amassés ont encadré les
équipes airstation adam matelly seront
votés à la syrie travail la série et
tous les sentiers plus difficile c'est
notre affaire
comme l'actuel mans michel santier la
cinquante ans d abandonner et il a marre
train de faire des travaux avec des
contrats de ses senneurs et il fait
plaisir que nous reconnu quand même pour
le f-35 au final j'ai mon boulot fait
tout le puits spécialité c'est le fait
avec you ses entretiens sur les tables
bancs les balais classe a fait tous
qu'il tombe des sites touristiques
vous êtes des sentiers de mafate à
l'époque à pied on a transporté le
cimade demain une chaleureuse cérémonie
au cours de laquelle chaque ouvrier a pu
partager ses plus belles anecdotes avec
la présidente